foreign
we have Luke in Denver hey Luke welcome
to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
um I got a multiple two-part question
um I co-owned a house with two High
School buddies of mine and I recently
decided I wanted to leave for a couple
reasons one is I'm not really feeling
comfortable in the partnership anymore I
feel like they're taking advantage of
the of the property and I'm feeling a
bit uh taken advantage of and the other
is I would love to use the money uh a
new house for my wife and son
so I've asked to be bought out and
they're kind of refusing to and they're
refusing to sell as well
what what is the uh what's the did you
all open an LLC or just somebody's yeah
we have it okay we have an LLC why don't
they want you to to buy out
I think they're they're a bit nervous to
eat um uh
uh alone right now with the interest
rates
but I'm asking I feel like to me I'm
asking a fair price I've got the house
appraised it came in at 800. we owe 440
on it so I'm asking a third of the
equity which is 120 and they're offering
me 80.
so I guess my question is like is
is that price fair to ask uh is are
there any other any other fees I
shouldn't consider
how old are you
I'm 32. okay is this your first like
deal that you tried to make like you and
your buddies had an idea like let's do
this and
is it true yeah it was uh
yeah it was a handshake too yeah did you
learn your lesson Luke yeah that's what
I'm getting at yeah
yeah for sure and for everyone listening
who's like ooh the real estate game I
can get in and me and two guys two
friends yeah we're gonna get this house
and it's gonna be awesome Luke tell
everyone why they shouldn't do that
yeah I mean they're still my friends I
like to think but it's it's definitely
changed everything changes changes your
relationship hey um and the way you said
it I want people to hear I want to get
out of this thing so that I can buy my
wife and kid a home
talk about putting the cart before the
horse right
yeah I mean it'd be nice to upgrade you
know help
just be there for my family sorry we're
not trying to just like dig you in the
ground Luke but we get this so often
it's just it's the reality and it's and
it's why we always say do not go into a
deal especially with debt uh with
friends and family because because now
you're stuck I mean like what what do we
think is a fair price like we could say
that yeah I don't know yeah but I mean
at the end of the day they have to be
the ones to decide right I mean there's
it's not split three ways you know
legally get to leave until you guys all
decide on something and so I
if I'm you you offered 120 they uh
counter offered 80. take the math off
the table and what you think fair market
value is and this everyone's coming up
with their own numbers
your goal now is you just want to get
out with some dignity so say let's just
set up 100 and let's shake hands and
let's be done with this thing and if
they say no forget you you can
um
it's been a few years since
I sat with a real estate attorney but
you can
basically you can go have a judge
dissolve the LLC and force the sale and
then split it that way
and that's a nuclear option okay okay
they can't just hold you hostage
um I think okay that would be for you to
talk to a lawyer though all right I'm
not in a position to give you legal
advice but my understanding is if I
remember correctly you can
ask a judge to dissolve it
um
all I have to say is dude if they're
gonna offer you 80 and at the end of the
day it's on Equity it's imaginary money
right it doesn't truly exist you haven't
lost anything take your 80 grand and
walk away
okay cool and I know it's frustrating
you took it on the chin it's gonna be
um Dave calls it stupid tax I wouldn't
call it I would say you learned your
lesson man it cost you some money and
the next time you're not gonna make the
same mistake okay yeah
it's a little bit of loss there
um versus what you were saying with the
equity but just to get out of the deal
Luke honestly you'll sleep better at
night and and hopefully it doesn't ruin
the Friendship either right but let's
say this though if his friends are
trying to rip him off or they're mad at
him or whatever friends yeah yeah you
know what I mean
having a bunch of friends but
it's true yeah I mean
but I wonder what their reasoning is
like what's the thing like you said you
were in this for a decade man yeah look
we're doing everything we always do is
in your work yeah I mean it's just it's
messy and then you you get married you
have a kid also in your priorities
changed